so the Avengers came out yeah armed
[ __ ] bah stop making comic book
movies they bomb it's clearly it's over
right
the trend is da dun dun folks you know
where they really hurt and ticket sales
yep
that bully kid didn't show it to the
premiere I know they offered him he was
clearly invited and he just didn't show
begged him see ya please we can go
please no I don't want to see this movie
thanks no thanks I don't want to see it
you saw it right Travis so good you
liked it huh I loved it were they
involved you do I need to see anything
before this or can I just go see it like
there's the any movies they came before
this one babies actually the first
Marvel movie well I wouldn't get
anything I need to see that as a sequel
to something where's the Iron Man doing
things there's nothing you need to see
see you next Tuesday so we go Tefft
comment you know what today is right
Travis what's the date check the
calendar it's like April 30th incorrect
I like dicks I was talking over it so
you know that wasn't me check the
calendar dude oh it's May 1st
I like dicks okay alright TEFL you
saying you like this movie I loved it oh
that was great I can't wait to see it
again alright so I see this I mean you
could but there's a handful of movies
you should if you saw beforehand you
would enjoy it more I left some say
which one like we're not gonna be
excited to see some of the characters
right like when the characters come on
screen you go oh my god the star-lord is
here oh no it's the magical V ladies
ever you got to see the movie do they
play Silver Surfer movie no to heaven I
mean they have a long time ago they did
yeah which is [ __ ] it's been some time
the Fantastic Four are not part of this
Marvel Universe well the Silver Surfer
is not in the Fantastic Four he worked
with the Fantastic Four's not in the
fantastic no I know but he was in that
universe of course it does it literally
relates directly to what I just said but
no the Fantastic Four were different so
you could do a Silver Surfer movie
without them saying the The Hulk and
spider-man you could just do one of
those you could
they work together and so this is this
is all the superheroes coming together
but did they know no but did they do
like a Silver Surfer movie what he
caught it I just told you that but why
not no sir phases we're surfers so
stupid why surgery where it's silvery
they've always hated the Silverson why
lame lasers it's cool who do you surf in
space he would [ __ ] ya in space [ __ ]
big joint wait a minute that movie
poster with the Silver Surfer on it
right there good no that's a comic book
that's different down one row over there
you go right there be a comic book to
know who it is clearly a poster no it's
not clearly a poster what is that but
what does that say what movie is that
could be a movie poster too sure I was
old Fantastic Four rise of the Silver
Surfer oh but he's I'm saying he's not
one of those four they could do a movie
about him as a comic book by himself
yeah he doesn't need the rest of the
Fantastic nor nobody he's strong enough
character on his own there was a Silver
Surfer comic book that was just him it
wasn't them weird that they have an
option didn't ya I don't know what I
mean what would he do he would surf he
would do you take a silver surfboard and
he was also silver Chrissy what he looks
like in the movie in the Fantastic Four
me yeah like what was this thing I don't
remember him I remember the Silver
Surfer I just don't remember what the
[ __ ] here is a silver man the
conserving space is that really all he
can do yeah that was the extent of his
powers well probably I bet if meteors
came he could probably punch him and
they break I'm [ __ ] pretty cool I'd
like to punch a meteor you would yeah
just watch it go what would it sound
like if you're punching a meteor I would
just jump like I'd be like then grab it
like someone told me that that was
really bothering them oh is that right
mm-hmm
Johnny torch there he is yeah that's
right the human torch there's a silver
surfer high above the earth I mean it
really is a character fame would create
okay yeah guy who surfs in space and
hits meteors over bokkeum silver surfin
so bad this is the Fantastic Four that
looks bad maybe yes I did I put my hairy
armpit on your shoulder
sweaty so they basically created the
Marvel Universe right after this movie
with one of the guys from this movie to
play Captain America Oh was he in this
didn't I just see him I just saw Chris a
that's Michael Chiklis no I always get
this too confused
yes you are you're seeing the Commish
right right this has no Chris Evans is
not the Commission this does not look
good this fantastic formally does not
look good you don't think so
no look at it look at him even the
graphics for that or not good see what
he's doing with the missiles though he's
riding around him was it no he was
slapping him out of the way oh I didn't
notice
yeah you know what it sounded like she
yeah I know on occasion yesterday with
who super [ __ ] doing a train
what tell me and grab them I was a cool
to [ __ ] you saying it to against the
wall [ __ ] just because he said
something Wow
are you gonna say are you gonna try to
see this Avengers movie you should see
black panther first what kind of forever
yeah you should see black panther okay
see guardians yeah what do you don't
care at Guardians note that little bit
what's the little creature in that [ __ ]
movie I am Groot Rocket Raccoon
oh [ __ ] rocky raccoon Rockets not rocky
wreck or whatever rocket can I tell you
the truth he threw the [ __ ] turkey
out the window he threw it out the
window when you said rocky racoon just
now I was like yeah I think that's what
it's called I don't know yeah yeah I
don't know whatever is the Rocket
Raccoon do you think Jim has to see the
first of each series you should see the
Avengers you should see the First
Avenger yeah you should see the Avengers
you should see Captain America Winter
Soldier gosh so much homework no you
don't have to but that's what I'm saying
like you don't have to I don't care
about anyway but it would be better
night there soldier
yeah winter soldiers great no it's not
some guy with the [ __ ] is that the
first Captain America no that's the
second one oh what's the first one the
birth of Captain America yeah Captain
America born in World War two
it's Captain America fresh out the womb
wooden you're the rest of these things
taking place in Captain America World
War two
yeah uh yeah so why is he still around
watchin
that's the winter Oh No so we get cool
ideals Winter Soldier is not Captain
with their referencing with those cold
after the mirrors no gives a fun home
why not explain all this [ __ ] to you how
to watch everywhere every Marvel comic
universe film and TV show in
chronological order okay you're gonna do
the series as well the TV shows okay all
right yeah all right so let's let's
let's schedule at Jim's next four years
of TV watching now you're gonna try to
see this one this movie while it's still
in theaters yeah okay all right so you
start with Captain America the First
Avenger Travis you're saying that's not
a good one though the First Avenger yeah
you that Winter Soldier was the good one
I said Winter Soldier is great because
the Jim said Winter Soldier sounds like
it sucks oh my god so the first Avengers
good see that are there any bad Marvel
movie yeah which one Thor - I heard that
was not good Thor won both the doors
Iron Man - that bad huh get there just
yeah I mean okay you can easily never
watch them okay but after you watch
Captain America the First Avenger
then you've got to watch agent Carter
seasons 1 and 2 how many episodes is
that like three or four I don't watch
any of the TV shows did you watch agent
Carter Rob no even you didn't what you
love TV loves - okay but you are gonna
watch both seasons of agent Carter
anyway probably watch them just to catch
you up to speed
okay then after you watch seasons 1 and
2 of agent Carter what's Iron Man 3
deviation Carter one shot Iron Man 3
DVDs a bonus feature on the Iron Man 3
DVD huh so you're gonna watch that yeah
to get a job just to catch but you don't
watch the movie you just watched it you
know what yeah well you will eventually
watch the movie but not in this is the
order you watch the bonus feature first
will you watch
agent Carter one shot from the Iron Man
3 DVD ok yeah yeah ok so you'll do that
yeah ok then you watch Iron Man mm-hmm
which is good I like Iron Man is great
yeah then you watch Iron Man 2 yeah then
you watch The Incredible Hulk ok then
you watch the consultant which is a
one-shot available on the Thor DVD
it's on the extras yeah did you watch
did you guys watch the consultant and
you were still able to follow the New
Avengers move maybe that's where I got
confused
okay okay okay well Jamie reports from
like not funny thing happened on the way
to Thor's hammer
so one shot Captain America First
Avenger DVD so you've already watched
Captain America First Avenger now out of
other movies you go to the extras you
find a funny thing happened on the way
to Thor's hammer then watch Thor then
ever thank you watch Thor then you can
watch The Avengers it's a good one then
you take your Avengers DVD look for item
47 which is a one-shot on the Avengers
DVD and that will take you through phase
1 yes now phase 2 things play out in
release order except guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 comes directly after the
first guardians meaning the movie has
been moved into phase 2 despite being a
phase 3 release okay well let's take a
look done let's scroll down and let's
see okay this is phase 2 you start with
Iron Man 3 great movie
you like Iron Man 3 but now I'm in 3
yeah I remember
ok ok then you take your DVD of Thor 2
you do not watch the film yeah but you
watch all hail the king one shot from
what is it what is all these one shots
on these DVDs that's probably to get you
to buy the DVD what is it one shot I'm
pretty sure the the extra scenes at the
end of the movies now dude are they on
the DVD as solo things or do you have to
fast-forward to the end of the movie I'm
guessing they're on the DVD as a soul
I'm going to say fast forward to the end
of the movie ok so go back to the list I
wonder if that's an iTunes extra I hope
so so so from now on to get these one
shots will fast forward so we'll go on
Thor the dark world and we'll fast
forward to the end of the movie do not
watch the movie yet of course not right
you have to watch it you just go to the
end of the movie just what was it a DVD
extra go to the end of the movie it's
after the credits just to make sure then
you watch the first seven episodes of
agents of shield cool ok so you ready
for that sure then you watch the sequel
to Thor then you dark world right then
you watch the next eight episodes of
agent sushi of season 1 episodes 8
through 16 have you watched the episodes
8 through 16 Rob No ok so you don't know
any any clue about this universe ok then
you watch Captain America the Winter
Soldier which is the sequel Travis loves
that one jerks off to it yeah
he's himself as a Winter Soldier oh yeah
instead of a summer flop right
good news Jim season one of agents of
shield is not done yet good because
after Captain America the Winter Soldier
you watch episode 17 through 22 of
agents of shield okay
okay so you'll do that Network TV
network perfect then you'll watch
guardians of galaxy Varney of the galaxy
al Guardian galaxy myself both of us
sounds - oh yeah great movie and then
you watch the sequel the other then the
entire first season of daredevil okay is
that available on Netflix yes that one
was awesome I see myself kind of as a
daredevil I'm glad I'm just done with
agents of shield Oh enough of that no
show that's actually you finished the
first season Yeah right after you watch
right after you watch daredevil season
one you have to watch episodes 1 through
19 of season 2 of agents of shield so
that's not not the whole season - in
just the first 19 after spider-man he
has to come in yet ago in order we
haven't gotten to spider-man yet oh
these are way back okay okay -
spider-man yet so then you watch an
event this the sequel to Avengers age of
Ultron that's no good
okay Rob goes and Travis goes okay we'll
give it one thumb and a half one thumb
down okay
then you finish up with season two of
agents of shield episode 20 through 22
okay right so that way you round it out
then you watch the Paul Rudd vehicle
ant-man what's that a superhero with
Twitter he's gonna stop the evil well
don't worry about who he's gonna stop
then after you watch ant-man in the film
you'll watch the entire first season of
Jessica Jones and the entire second
season of daredevil then you will turn
on agents of shield and watch the first
19 episodes of season three so two full
seasons and then one group of 19 shows
this is gonna take me for five days okay
all right and but at that point you're
done with phase two okay out of the
three phases are you ready for Phase
three yep
okay you'll start by watching Captain
America Civil War cricket movie that's
great if you're gonna watch anything
before you go see infinity where you got
you should watch the little war okay
okay okay oh my god there's so many then
you watch episodes 20 through 22 of
agency good show I've never watched an
episode okay and then Luke Cage season 1
the whole first season yeah
then Doctor Strange okay awesome oh then
you get a nice treat you get to watch
episodes one through eight the first
eight episodes of season four of agents
of shield who knew there were four
seasons people huh not me nope me
neither
then there's a oh my god then there was
a series called agents of shield
slingshot which is just on the web so
you watch that whole series is that then
you watch episode ah [ __ ] crisis 9
through 22 so the next 12 episodes of
agents of shield agents of shield is a
60 minute show that you have now you've
now committed in eighty eight episodes
oh you knock out those commercial that's
like 43 minutes plus the web sear the
web series might actually make up for
the commercials yeah yeah yeah
then great after you're done season four
of agents of shield I've never even
heard of this show you watch Iron Fist
season one that one sucked
oh sorry great but you're never gonna
get this movie if you don't want to have
to watch the first season of iron ok is
I his Iron Fist make an appearance in
the film nope no spoilers come on Rob
damn like the big Iron Fist fan is
getting ready to go to the movies that's
right then oh this is a big one too then
you watch the season one of the
defenders it was ok what is that it's
iron fist Jessica Jones daredevil and
Luke Cage all together it's not Netflix
yeah it's a Netflix then
you get the spiderman spiderman
homecoming you get to watch but where's
the other spider-man's well those aren't
in the Marvel Universe Jack's only
technically spider-man I believe makes
his debut in civil wars that right Yeah
right
is he in the movie he's in civil war
okay and then you get to watch
spider-man homecoming which is to my
surprise I watched it I really enjoyed
that movie because it was a continuation
of Civil War you don't need to watch
another goddamn movie about how a kid
got bit by they don't they don't do
anything I'm so sick of the reboot to
that dumb story we don't get it they
don't do any of it
Marissa Tomei isn't it right shoots us
web and the web bouncing hang on to the
building site Vinnie ug positraction
[Laughter]
enough already positraction know what
it's like something you'd put in your
[ __ ] singles profile on Grindr once
you get through spider-man homecoming I
know what you have to watch in humans
the Punisher and Runaways season one of
each show so it's three season ones
right yeah I haven't watched in humans
but the Punisher was awesome
Oh run away was poopoo oh not great okay
then then you can get to Black Panther
which is great Black Panther was awesome
what kind of forever
what kind of forever after that you have
to dive into season two of Jessica Jones
which suffered her right Rob you've seen
all these oh yeah yeah you love this I
love this stuff Rob loves TV look what
you do after Jessica Jones season to
season [ __ ] [ __ ] the first 14
episodes
god damn it up season 5 why wouldn't I
be 1 through 14 right then cloak into
anger season 1 which I don't know what
that is do you watch that Rob
cloak-and-dagger no okay well you
probably are not gonna get this man I
remember them from comic books but I
haven't seen the show then thor ragnarok
pre-movie
that was good that was the third Thor
yeah
very funny then then Jim Jeff Goldblum's
in it that's when you go see Avengers
infinity all right so this is nine days
worth of stuff nine days were the stuff
so I can go in ten days it took nine
days to read it yeah a lot then you'll
be all ready okay they were taking great
pride in it they were like hey to
everybody who's saying there's no not
enough backstory for Avengers infinity
war take a look at this and they showed
all eighteen movie posters Rob you've
seen most of this stuff yeah have you
seen all the films yes you saw all
eighteen movies I'm almost positive I
have I don't think I've missed one I
mean yeah how about the x-men yeah I
love the x-men that's not part of this
universe not part of the universe
because Sony and Fox and Marvel all have
this yet stupid it's not part of the
Marvel Universe oh yeah they are you are
forgetting one go ahead Jim in New
Jersey what's up Joe yeah I was
wondering grocery man they're afraid
without shine everybody
saving people from their groceries
falling on the ground grocery man was a
big hit so I remember that yeah you're a
grocery man two wilted lettuce is what
I'm working on now is that one instead
of going after falling groceries he's
going after groceries that are maybe a
day or two past Uxbridge checks
expiration dates and he flies in and he
takes the wilted lettuce and he flies
into the ocean and drops it in the ocean
so he can fly of course he can and he's
using green cape with a G on it he's
using that power to help people go
grocery shopping yes but he flies he
that get all the wilted lettuce he flies
into the oh she drops it like nuclear
weapons right he didn't think to do more
with his ability to fly no no he was
actually criticized in one of the in one
of the film's what did what was said
about him because there was a there was
kind of a there was a murder and a rape
taking place right and he flew over to
get spoiled milk that's it I don't alert
the police or anything he did no he
didn't even call or not even care no
nothing because he says yeah that's a
bad thing but if somebody drinks spoiled
milk then all of a sudden they don't
show up for work if you don't show up
for work this Domino was was the rape
happening in the grocery store no just
an on the ground on his way okay so
there's a murder - it was an ax murder
rape but it wasn't technically within
his jurisdiction
just didn't care he didn't let anybody
know if there had been a murder rape in
the grocery store when you stopped it
only if they were knocking groceries off
the shelves to save the groceries he
would save the groceries from falling to
the ground does he not think to himself
as much as people might miss work
because of spoiled milk
they may also miss work because of being
murdered or raped and raised victims do
miss work something they really do I
know he's concerned with you you could
only fight so many battles right like
people in PETA aren't doing a bunch of
other things they're just fighting in
PETA so that's kind of how it is so he
lets any crime it could be it could just
be a it could be an armed robbery he
flies right over it you know what's sad
grocery man would actually fit into the
Justice League that dog [ __ ] movie he
would it's just terrible
saving groceries the just grocery man
two wilted lettuce
yeah people thought was a little long
came in just under four hours all my job
and people thought like Once Upon a Time
in America yeah the people who thought
that was a little long because two hours
and 40 minutes were just close ups of
the lettuce wilted and in his hand like
him examining it no he just rose and
drops in the ocean but that was two
hours and forty minutes and a film that
came in just under four hours of just
him examining lettuce to examine it yeah
is that to figure out if it's wilted or
not yep I see yeah I was that a combined
total of time or two montage okay and
they're playing take you to the limit by
Scarface over and over so this is in two
hours 40 minutes like throughout the
movie montage it's 1/2 hour and 40
minute montage if he's right after the
credits opening credits yeah oh the
opening credits is uh he wakes up out of
a he's in bed right he gets out of bed
and he's wearing his grocery man clothes
he sleeps in them I see and he says I
got to go check the lettuce right man he
flies there over the over the attack in
the murder and he lands the grocery
store than the credits are finished and
he's just going through it's a montage
take it to the limit yeah and he's just
examining this is two hours and 40
minutes
I think he's exactly asleep the song yep
just this part just this part no that's
just the intro yep now they suffer this
so you must hear that that one heart
that goes in the beginning of the box
yup or it goes yeah that comes in
everyone examining wilted lettuce
seconds in every 10 seconds for 2 hours
and 40 minutes
yeah then at the end and then at the end
fly like it after two hours of 40 bits
he flies it to the ocean and drops it in
the center of the ocean cuz he realizes
it is indeed with him yeah and then he
hears oh no and an old lady has dropped
her honey jar okay and does he pick it
up or yes I see okay in China oh so he
hears grocery stores throughout the
world he flies over the really quickly
around the planet he can do that and he
flies through a window and he grabs the
honey jar before it hits the ground it
seems like he has all the powers of
Superman and he places it up on top of
the table is this just Superman but in a
grocery store no those are incredibly
quick reflexes yeah he hears oh no but
it's in Chinese and so they translate oh
no and then he and then in his mind he
hears the whoosh of the honey jar
falling he flies you know well from the
center of the ocean to China and he
stops it before hits the ocean this is
the ocean in Indian Ocean oh yes so so
you know who else has reflexes that are
that quick and supersonic hearing like
that Oh Superman
yeah maybe it just sounds like Superman
in a grocery store except this is a
grocery man except grocery man goes to
the Indian Ocean to drop off Superman
medals and people's affairs right and
grocery man does not know no I did see
Justice League with Superman Batman
Wonder Woman the flash and who's that
robot guy Larry then Larry who him the
robot manners yeah Larry the robot guy
cyborg yeah
flash Superman Batman and Wonder Woman
it was not good Aquaman loved it Wonder
Woman was amazing who's behind the beard
in the back he looks Aquaman not beer
he's most have a [ __ ] blonde hair
isn't a beard no that's sexy yes Jason
Momoa is sexy Aquaman and he is hella
sexy
let me see ocular that's in that new
meme right yeah with Henry yeah whatever
his name is I think so it's a great man
look at how [ __ ] sexy that dude not
sexy isn't [ __ ] it looks faster super
sir no fat Aquaman most of the movies
got a shirt on it no he's [ __ ] dumb
Aquaman yeah
fad there come on nah he looks too buff
you think so he's too honestly is that
does look like Aquaman looks like
[ __ ] gentle Ben's friend Grizzly
Adams you know I got you know I got your
Aquaman being that buff show me the
original comic book Jack walk with his
[ __ ] blond hair show gay porn star
Aquaman that's the one I like Vinnie
chase played Aquaman like 10 or 12 years
ago and yeah that's kind of the
definitive Aquaman yeah I feel Oh
Jason Momoa does have a lot to live up
to hey yo that's Aquaman no he's a
blond-haired guy in the water big green
forearm Jim just likes like Fabio
romance novels I like the comic book to
look like the comic book right they made
him look different how come a Superman
isn't a beard there you go there's
Aquaman a mustache ba ba ba ba ba ba sue
brain comes out he's got [ __ ] a gray
ponytail they changed Batman they put
nipples on the suit at one point yeah I
guess they did you don't mind that a
nice shiny leather he's made more than
Morgan Freeman do you hear that Morgan
Freeman they say was having a sexual
relationship with a stepbrother hear
that is that true I don't know yes
somebody said that yeah I don't I don't
know Maddie Nia is daughter got into
porn right you're the girl I didn't know
that was Laurence Fishburne Lawrence
that was my Tennison operation no he um
either me too or a racial moment no no
Morgan Freeman's granddaughter was
murdered his grace grace step
granddaughter but they said that there
was some kind of weird like her
boyfriend killed her I guess over song
right that's that was wrong for saying
and they would send a file for it he's
on trial maybe he didn't do it yeah we
have to say he's accused of it don't you
do what's it called impression I'm
Morgan Freeman I do like how would he
announced to his fan he's actually doing
the grocery man voiceover how would he
describe grocery man going to the he
would spend all day looking through
wilted lettuce so those are the words or
how would Morgan Freeman say that's how
you do it oh geez and he would scroll
head of lettuce after head of lettuce
after head of lettuce looking for wilted
parts and then he doesn't say anything
in our 25 minutes Oh My gods and then
take it to the limit starts no they go
Tate's limits under the voiceover oh and
they did he just that voice over then
it's like an hour and 40 minutes of
talking just there's just a taken to the
limits looking through the wilted
lettuce I meant - for sir I know an
outward 40 and then walking firm comes
back in with his affiliates for an hour
no I know you didn't say anything for
now he comes back in and he says and
he'd still never get tired no matter how
many wilted lettuce heads he found it
was quiet again from the hour he's doing
this directly in the style of Shawshank
Redemption and the martial arts and then
at the end as he go and then he found
the wilted lettuce now they're just
dumping him back it just doesn't compare
the rest of the film at one point it
does when oh yeah you wrote this you
know I bet that's been a while when not
rid of Sam it's a four-hour movie you
can't remember that's true that's true
oh I know anyway when he goes to China
it catches the jar Morgan says ax and
another tumble and honey jar is saved
but that's the first time charge yes
well he means in history there's no need
to [ __ ] on it was a hit film there's no
need to nitpick it was a huge Lisa he
was just saying overall his crevice is
[ __ ] sexy - well yeah step
granddaughter yes